It's a typical camp, all the normal activities-- canoeing, archery, sports. There are two girls who everybody calls the homesick girls, who will cheerfully identify themselves that way to anybody they meet.
这是一个典型的夏令营，有所有常见的活动——划独木舟、射箭、体育运动。有两个女孩被大家称为“思乡女孩”，她们会乐呵呵地向遇到的任何人做自我介绍。
She wants to go home.
她想回家。
I do. I swear to God, I want to go home.
我是真的，我发誓，我想回家。
The food is like the best.
这里的食物简直是最好的。
I want to go home too.
我也想回家。
Including me.
包括我。
Because it's a pretty upscale camp, there's also horseback riding. And on the rifle range, suburban girls from Chicago's North Shore lay on their bellies in sniper position while a real former Israeli soldier barks orders about how to shoot.
因为这是一个相当高档的夏令营，还有骑马活动。在靶场上，来自芝加哥北岸郊区的女孩们趴在地上，摆出狙击手的姿势，而一位真正的前以色列士兵在旁边大声下达射击指令。
I know it's really hard for you ladies to keep it quiet, but try, OK? Aim and fire.
我知道各位女士要保持安静很难，但试试看，好吗？瞄准，射击。
[GUNSHOTS]
[枪声]
The boys' cabins are all named after Indian tribes, the girls' cabins are all named after women's colleges. So perky little suburban kids are constantly informing you, I'm an Apache, I'm Mohawk, I'm in Vassar, I'm in Bryn Mawr. And it seems pretty simple, but everybody here will tell you, no one back home understands it. None of their friends, nobody. There is just a gap between camp people and non-camp people.
男生宿舍都以印第安部落命名，女生宿舍都以女子学院命名。所以，那些充满活力的郊区孩子们会不停地告诉你：“我是阿帕奇人”、“我是莫霍克人”、“我在瓦萨学院”、“我在布林莫尔学院”。这听起来很简单，但这里的每个人都会告诉你，家里的人根本不理解。她们的朋友，没人懂。这就是“夏令营圈内人”与“圈外人”之间的隔阂。
I know. All the time during school, I'm like, I want to go to camp. I want to do this.
我知道。上学期间，我总是说，我想去夏令营，我想做这些事。
Camp is all I talk about during the year.
夏令营是我这一年里唯一谈论的话题。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. My friends get so mad at me. They're like, we don't want to hear about camp anymore.
是的。我的朋友们对我感到很烦。她们说，我们不想再听夏令营的事情了。
Because everything that goes on at home, you can always think of something that relates something that happened at camp. And so then you tell that, and they'll be like, camp? We've heard about camp way too much.
因为家里发生的每一件事，你总能想到与之相关的夏令营经历。于是你就开始讲，她们就会说：“又是夏令营？我们听得够多了。”
It's also little stories you tell, and you think they're so funny and everybody in your cabin understands them. And then you go home and you're laughing, and they give you a look like, what are you talking about? Like, that's stupid.
还有你讲的那些小故事，你觉得非常有趣，宿舍里的每个人都能听懂。但等你回到家讲出来，她们却是一副“你在说什么”的表情，好像觉得那很傻。
Well, today on our program, we try to bridge the gap between camp people and non-camp people who try to understand what is the cult-like, mystical connection some people feel with their summer camps? From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天节目里，我们试图弥合“夏令营圈内人”与“圈外人”之间的隔阂，并试图弄明白，为什么有些人会对夏令营有一种类似邪教般的神秘联结？这里是WBEZ芝加哥和公共广播国际频道，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, Notes On Camp. Six different notes, some recorded at a summer camp, and some amazing stories that actually came from you, people who listen to this program and called us up to talk camp. Stay with us.
今天节目的主题是“夏令营笔记”。六则不同的笔记，有些是在夏令营现场录制的，还有一些是来自你们的精彩故事，那些收听本节目并打电话来分享夏令营经历的听众。请继续收听。
Most of today's program takes place in Michigan, not far from Paw Paw. Two affiliated camps, Greenwoods and Lake of the Woods, one is a boys camp, one's a girls camp. But they sit on the same land. They share everything. Basically they function as one camp. Producer Julie Snyder and I spent a fair amount of time there.
今天大部分节目是在密歇根州的波波镇（Paw Paw）附近拍摄的。那里有两个联营夏令营：格林伍德（Greenwoods）和森林湖（Lake of the Woods），一个是男生营，一个是女生营。但它们位于同一片土地上，共享一切。基本上，它们被视为一个夏令营。我和制片人朱莉·斯奈德在那里度过了一段时光。
Julie usually hung out with the girls, I usually stayed with the boys. Here then, our findings.
朱莉通常和女生待在一起，我通常和男生待在一起。以下就是我们的见闻。
Note number one. Mr. Popular.
笔记一：人气王。
Let's try the chorus again, because something in that last part is weird.
我们再试一次副歌，最后那部分有点怪。
Counselors David Himmel and Dean Hines practice a song for Saturday night's camp show.
辅导员大卫·希梅尔和迪恩·海因斯正在为周六晚上的营地演出排练歌曲。
All right. Ready?
好了，准备好了吗？
Yeah.
好了。
OK. (SINGING) And even Hitler had a girlfriend who he could always call. She'd always be there for him, in spite of all his faults. He was the worst guy ever, vile and despised. Even Hitler had a girlfriend, so why can't-- (SPEAKING) It goes to high there. That's the problem, It's going too high.
好的。（唱歌）甚至希特勒也有个女朋友，随时都能呼唤。无论他有什么缺点，她总会在他身边。他曾是史上最糟糕的人，卑劣且受人鄙视。甚至希特勒也有个女朋友，所以为什么不能——（说话）调子太高了。问题就在这，调子升得太高了。
You think so?
你觉得吗？
(SINGING) Even Hitler had a girlfriend, so I can't--
（唱歌）甚至希特勒也有个女朋友，所以我不能——
David Himmel has been coming to this camp since he was 11. Now, he's a counselor and a sailing instructor, a college sophomore, a boy with clear, blue eyes who actually has no trouble getting a girlfriend. Like a lot of campers and counselors we met at this camp, he says that all the best moments of his life have either been at camp or with camp people.
大卫·希梅尔从11岁起就一直来这个夏令营。现在，他是辅导员和帆船教练，大二学生，一个有着清澈蓝眼睛的男孩，他其实根本不缺女朋友。和我们在这个营地见到的许多营员和辅导员一样，他说他一生中最美好的时光要么是在夏令营里，要么是和夏令营里的人在一起。
Camp. it's number one with everything I do, I guess. Camp is just-- it's kind of ridiculous, but it's everything. It changes people's lives. People base their life around camp. I would not be who I am if it wasn't for camp.
夏令营，我想它是我所做一切的第一位。夏令营就是……虽然有点可笑，但它是全部。它改变了人们的生活。人们以夏令营为中心建立自己的生活。如果没有夏令营，我就不会是现在的我。
Who would you be?
那你本来会是谁？
I don't know. I think I enjoy things better now because of camp. When you live so close to people like this-- and it's sort of like college-- but everybody at camp is just real close knit. It's like a bond that just happens. And that's why a day at camp is like two weeks in real life. It's like a time warp here.
我不知道。我觉得因为夏令营，我现在更能享受生活了。当你和这样的人住得这么近时——这有点像大学——但夏令营里的每个人都紧密相连。这是一种自然产生的羁绊。这就是为什么在夏令营度过一天就像现实生活中的两周。这里就像一个时间漩涡。
And people at summer camp treat David with a deference that few of us get in real life. He and I are walking around camp one day when a group of 13-year-old girls comes up to us.
而且夏令营里的人对待大卫表现出一种我们大多数人在现实生活中很难得到的尊敬。有一天我和他在营地里散步时，一群13岁的女孩向我们走来。
He is the best counselor.
他是最棒的辅导员。
This is my fan club. [LAUGHS]
这是我的粉丝俱乐部。[笑]
He's the best counselor in the world, and we love him so much.
他是世界上最好的辅导员，我们太爱他了。
What makes him the best counselor in the world?
是什么让他成为世界上最好的辅导员的？
He takes us sailing.
他带我们去划船。
He takes us sailing. He's cool. We made him all this food, made him a song.
他带我们去划船。他太酷了。我们为他做了很多食物，还为他写了首歌。
And we have a song for him.
我们还为他准备了一首歌。
Let me hear his song.
让我听听他的歌。
No, you guys don't know it. I'll sing it.
不，你们不知道这首歌。我来唱。
(SINGING) All across the big lake, Davey's the one that keeps us awake. We got the rudder, we got the sail. Davey, [CLAPS] [CLAPS] he's our male. We got a D-A-V-E-Y. We got a D-A-V-E-Y. We got a D-A-V-E-Y. Davey, [CLAPS] [CLAPS] he's our guy. D-A-V-E-Y, Davey, Davey. D-A-V-E-Y, Davey's number one. Davey's number one, Davey's number one. D-A-V-E-Y, Davey's number one. Whoo!
（唱歌）穿过大湖，戴维是让我们清醒的人。我们有舵，我们有帆。戴维，[拍手] [拍手] 他是我们的好男孩。我们有D-A-V-E-Y。我们有D-A-V-E-Y。我们有D-A-V-E-Y。戴维，[拍手] [拍手] 他是我们的好哥们。D-A-V-E-Y，戴维，戴维。D-A-V-E-Y，戴维是第一名。戴维是第一名，戴维是第一名。D-A-V-E-Y，戴维是第一名。喔！
It's time for lunch. Everyone, get out of your cabins, please, immediately, and head over to get some delicious food. That would mean stop playing ping pong right now. Let's go. Go to lunch. Almuerzo. La comida.
午餐时间到了。大家请立刻离开宿舍，去吃美味的午餐。这意味着现在停止玩乒乓球。我们走吧。去吃饭。午餐时间到了。
I sit next to Dave at lunch one day. In the mess hall, everybody at camp eats together, and it is constant singing. The girls have their own traditional songs, the boys have theirs. Most of the cabins have songs of their own. After the oldest girls' cabin sings their cheer, which, by tradition, is chanted so quickly that none of the boys and none of the younger girls can figure out what the words are, the oldest boys' cabin, the Mohawks, stands to respond.
有一天我坐在戴夫旁边吃午餐。在食堂里，夏令营的所有人都聚在一起吃饭，到处都在唱歌。女生有她们传统的歌，男生也有他们的。大多数宿舍都有自己的歌。在年龄最大的女生宿舍唱完她们的助威词后——按照传统，这助威词喊得极快，以至于所有男生和低龄女生都听不出唱的是什么词——年龄最大的男生宿舍“莫霍克人”站起来回应。
(CHANTING) Mohawk once, Mohawk twice. [INAUDIBLE]
（呼喊）莫霍克一次，莫霍克两次。[听不清]
Dave turns to me.
戴夫转向我。
I made that up.
那是我编的。
What are the words?
歌词是什么？
Well, it's a radio version of the original Mohawk-- it's called the Mohawk Song. It goes, Mohawk once, Mohawk twice. Holy jumping, golly gee, Cheez Whiz, we're the best that ever lived. And it's a clean version. There's a dirty version with swear words in it. And we started singing it at lunch. We kept on getting in trouble, I said, well, we got to make a clean one.
嗯，那是原始莫霍克歌的广播版，叫“莫霍克之歌”。歌词是：莫霍克一次，莫霍克两次。老天啊，天哪，我的天，我们是史上最强的。这是干净的版本。还有一个带脏话的脏版本。我们开始在午餐时唱那个。我们一直惹麻烦，所以我就说，我们得编一个干净的版本。
Radio edit.
广播编辑版。
And it just popped into my head, and it's kind of cool hearing that. I started all these things.
它突然就从我脑子里冒出来了，听起来挺酷的。所有这些东西都是我发起的。
Like what else?
比如还有什么？
Well, when somebody has a birthday, we sing "Happy Birthday" to them. And this is kind of dumb, but I get a kick out of it. We go, (SINGING) Happy birthday to you-- and last year, I went, whoo! And now everybody does it. And it's just kind of cool. You make stuff up, and--
嗯，有人过生日时，我们唱“生日快乐”。这有点傻，但我很喜欢。我们唱（唱歌）祝你生日快乐——去年我加了一句“喔！”。现在每个人都跟着唱了。这挺酷的。你编造了一些东西，然后——
It survives.
它就流传下来了。
David's a force. David is the one who people turn to. David is the man, at least when it comes to some things. The night of the last camp dance, David wanders the grounds, keeping his eye out for the 13-year-old boys in his cabin. He spots two of them sitting with two girls, and he says to me--
大卫是个核心人物。大卫是大家求助的对象。大卫是这里的关键人物。最后一个营地舞会的当晚，大卫在营地里闲逛，留意着他宿舍里那些13岁的男孩。他发现其中两个正和两个女孩坐在一起，他对我说道——
You got four 13-year-olds just chilling in a circle.
看，四个13岁的孩子正围成一圈。
Sitting on the ground.
坐在地上。
Sitting on the ground, Indian style. It's like a powwow. And Dan is with Amanda, and he's going to try and kiss her tonight.
以印第安盘腿姿势坐在地上。就像个部落聚会。丹和阿曼达在一起，他今晚打算试着亲吻她。
Has he ever kissed a girl?
他亲过女孩子吗？
That's what I asked him. I said, have you ever kissed a girl? He said, well, not French. I said, do you got the gall to do it? Can you do it? You need some pumping up? He's like, no, I got it.
我问过他。我说，你亲过女孩子吗？他说，嗯，不是法式那种。我说，你有胆量去做吗？你能做到吗？需要打打气吗？他说，不用，我有把握。
Which one is Amanda?
阿曼达是哪一个？
Amanda's the one with the hair braid.
阿曼达是那个编了头发的女孩。
The beads in her hair?
头发上有珠子的那个？
Yeah.
对。
Now, Dan is just sitting there, kind of quiet. But he's not really saying very much.
现在，丹就坐在那，有点安静。但他没怎么说话。
He's a quiet kid. I mean, he doesn't really say anything unless he has something to say. Hey, buddy. He's a cool kid. He's a really--
他是个安静的孩子。我的意思是，除非他有话要说，否则他不怎么开口。嘿，伙计。他是个很酷的孩子。他真的很——
How do you think he's doing?
你觉得他表现如何？
In the cabin, or in general?
是在宿舍里，还是总体而言？
No, how do you think he's doing over there, right now, at this moment?
不，你觉得他现在表现如何，就在这一刻？
Oh, with Amanda? I think he's doing good. She's really into him. In that hair thing, she's got three beads that says, A heart D. Amanda loves Dan. And I talked to her, and I'm like, so how's Dan? (IMITATING AMANDA) Oh, he's fine. You like him? (IMITATING AMANDA) Yeah. So I think he's doing good.
哦，和阿曼达在一起？我觉得他表现不错。她很喜欢他。在发辫里，她编了三个珠子，写着“A心D”。阿曼达爱丹。我和她聊过，我说，丹怎么样？（模仿阿曼达）哦，他很好。你喜欢他吗？（模仿阿曼达）是的。所以我认为他表现不错。
One of the things he most likes about camp, David tells me, is the constant, ongoing drama. It is a soap opera. And David is one of the people who's always making up skits and songs based on the hundred inside jokes that are at the heart of any camp humor. Later that night, after the dance, all of David's 13-year-olds are back in the Cheyenne cabin, getting ready for bed. And David gets a report from each one.
大卫告诉我，他最喜欢夏令营的一点就是持续不断的剧情。这简直就是一部肥皂剧。而大卫总是根据任何夏令营幽默核心里的那些内部笑话来编造短剧和歌曲。那天晚些时候，舞会结束后，大卫那群13岁的孩子都回到了夏安宿舍准备睡觉。大卫收到了每个人的汇报。
Keith.
基思。
What?
怎么了？
What are you smiling about?
你在笑什么？
Nothing.
没什么。
And Dan? Nothing happened?
丹呢？什么都没发生吗？
We just talked the whole night. And, well, we were just sitting there [LAUGHS] the whole night.
我们聊了一整晚。嗯，我们就在那儿坐了一整晚。[笑]
Why are you so embarrassed?
你为什么这么尴尬？
We were just talking the whole night about really nothing. And then, just after, we-- I didn't get anywhere. I just hugged her at the end. I didn't really get anywhere.
我们聊了一整晚，其实什么都没聊。然后，在那之后，我们——我什么都没做成。最后只是抱了她一下。没进展。
If you had tried, do you think you could have?
如果你试过，你觉得你能成功吗？
Yeah, I would have.
能，我能做到。
So it's your fault, then.
所以是你的错咯。
No, it's her fault.
不，是她的错。
Why is it her fault?
为什么是她的错？
Because she didn't-- well, I could have made a move, I guess. But she didn't-- it's her fault. She--
因为她没——嗯，我想我可以主动点。但她没——这是她的错。她——
She's not going to make the move.
她不会主动出手的。
Yeah, I think she likes you. You got to go for it.
是啊，我觉得她喜欢你。你得主动出击。
She's got that thing in her hair, one of the kids says. They all resolve that Dan will get another chance. David's got his back. David will see that things go OK for him.
其中一个孩子说，她头发上有那个饰物。他们一致认为丹会有下一次机会。大卫会支持他。大卫会确保事情对他来说进展顺利。
[MUSIC - "I WISH I WAS HIM" BY BEN LEE]
[音乐 - 本·李的《我希望是我》]
Note number two, Fear. Sure, kids today, so sophisticated. They have email and PlayStation. It is encouraging, then, to realize that if you get them living in the woods a few weeks, they can be entertained by some of the most stupidly primitive forms of entertainment available since the dawn of civilization. I'm talking about scary stories. Every camp has got them. This is so true you do not even need me to tell this to you. 12-year-olds know this.
笔记二：恐惧。当然，现在的孩子太世故了。他们有电子邮件和PlayStation。意识到如果把他们扔到树林里生活几周，他们就能被自文明诞生以来最愚蠢、最原始的娱乐方式所吸引，这真的很令人振奋。我说的是恐怖故事。每个夏令营都有。这是千真万确的，根本不需要我来告诉你。12岁的孩子都知道这一点。
You know how every camp has their little ghost story?
你知道每个夏令营都有那种小鬼故事吗？
Ours is about--
我们的是关于——
We have the story of Turtleman.
我们有“龟人”（Turtleman）的故事。
I'll tell it.
我来讲。
OK. Sarah will tell it.
好吧。萨拉来讲。
The Turtleman story? All right, I'll tell it.
龟人的故事？好吧，我来讲。
Long-- you can help me out if I do it wrong. A long, long time ago, there was this counselor who was really mean to all of his campers and everything.
很久以前——如果我讲错了你们可以帮我补充。很久很久以前，有一个辅导员对所有营员都很刻薄。
I can't remember how many years ago it was. But supposedly, there was this counselor, and he was dishonorably discharged from the military. And he was real, real mean to all the campers. He always took their food and stuff and, like, stole their clothes and stuff like that.
我不记得是多少年前了。但据说，有个辅导员因为不光彩的原因被军队开除了。他真的、真的对所有营员都很刻薄。他总是抢走他们的食物，偷走他们的衣服之类的。
He would beat them and everything, and his campers were so afraid of him.
他会打他们，所以营员们都很怕他。
And he said, if you tell anybody about me--
他说，如果你们把我的事告诉任何人——
Yeah, he said, if you tell anyone about me, then I'll kill you all.
对，他说，如果你们把我的事告诉别人，我就杀了你们所有人。
And he would read their letters, so they couldn't write home and tell about it.
而且他会拆看他们的信，所以他们不能写信回家告状。
And one year, these campers had a foot locker filled with fireworks. But he found them, and he took them from them.
有一年，这些营员有一个装满烟花的行李箱。但他发现了，并把烟花抢走了。
And so, on the Fourth of July, the guys were like, oh, well, he's so mean. We should try and kill him ourselves. We're not really this vicious here, but-- so they put fireworks under his bed. And once he had fallen asleep, they all went up there and they lit--
所以，在那一年的7月4日，大家觉得他太坏了。我们应该试着自己除掉他。虽然我们平时没那么邪恶，但——他们在他床下放了烟花。等他睡着后，他们就去点燃了——
No, he was smoking.
不对，他当时在抽烟。
Oh.
哦。
He was smoking a cigarette.
他在抽烟。
And then I guess they could smoke in the cabins because, I mean, it was many, many years ago, and I guess there wasn't a law. And he took them, and he put the fireworks underneath his bed, and he fell asleep.
我觉得当时他们在宿舍里可以抽烟，因为那是很多年前的事了，我想那时候还没有法律。他把烟花放在床下，然后睡着了。
And, well, a cigarette fell out of his hand and into the foot locker.
然后，他手中的烟头掉进了行李箱里。
The fireworks got lit, and he exploded. And he ran into the lake on fire.
烟花被点燃了，他爆炸了。他着着火跑进了湖里。
And supposedly, he's still alive.
据说，他现在还活着。
Every Fourth of July, he comes back, and he takes revenge on a camper and pulls him into the lake.
每年的7月4日，他都会回来，对营员进行报复，把他们拖进湖里。
Every Fourth of July, he comes out of the lake and takes someone in for his next victim. But what really happens on the Fourth of July is either a counselor or one of the Mohawks, without asking anyone, goes into the lake and comes out and scares the heck out of everyone.
每年的7月4日，他都会从湖里出来，把人抓去做下一个牺牲品。但实际上7月4日那天发生的事是，某个辅导员或莫霍克人，不通知任何人，跳进湖里，然后出来把大家吓个半死。
But yeah, some of them really believe it. So it's cool.
但有些孩子真的相信这个。所以很酷。
The older kids are funny in how they handle the ghost stories with the little kids. When producer Julie Snyder was interviewing a group of girls about Turtleman during arts and crafts one day, there was this moment. 12-year-olds Rebecca Stern and Sarah Turkisher were talking about how they used to believe in Turtleman a few years ago when they were little, when, suddenly, some of the younger girls sitting around, Jenny Mayer and Nicole Horn, piped up, asking, well, is it true? And then the older girls, unsure of what to say, in the course of 17 seconds take every possible position on the issue. Here's the tape.
大孩子在应对恐怖故事时对待小孩子的方式很有趣。制片人朱莉·斯奈德有一天在手工课上采访一群女孩关于“龟人”的故事时，出现了这样的一幕。12岁的丽贝卡·斯特恩和萨拉·图尔基舍谈论她们小时候是如何相信“龟人”的故事，这时，坐在一旁的几个年纪较小的女孩——珍妮·梅耶和妮可·霍恩——突然插话问：“那是真的吗？”接着，大孩子们不知道该怎么回答，在17秒内对这个问题采取了所有可能的立场。这是录音。
And then you tell all the little kids, but you're kind of cautious--
然后你们告诉所有小孩子，但你们又有点谨慎——
It's not true, is it?
那不是真的，对吧？
No.
不是。
You said it was true.
你刚才还说是真的。
It is true.
是真的。
Who made it up, though?
不过那是谁编的？
It's a legend.
这是个传说。
It's a camp legend.
这是夏令营传说。
There's always a legend of camp.
夏令营总是有传说的。
Yeah.
是的。
So is it true, or isn't it true?
所以它到底是真是假？
It's not.
不是真的。
You'll never know.
你永远不会知道。
Time does not tell.
时间不会给出答案。
No. You'll find out.
不。你会发现真相的。
The 10-year-olds seem to sit on the cusp of belief and disbelief when it comes to stories like this. For them, talking about these stories is just part of the process of trying to puzzle out, how does the world exactly work? When you're 10, remember, people are constantly telling you scary stories-- of murders, of kids with guns-- and the thing is, a lot of those stories are true. So you're still figuring out, where is the line between fiction and nonfiction?
10岁的孩子在听到这些故事时，似乎正处于相信与怀疑的边缘。对他们来说，谈论这些故事是理解世界如何运作的过程。记住，当你是10岁时，人们总是告诉你恐怖故事——关于谋杀、关于拿着枪的孩子——关键在于，其中很多故事是真的。所以你还在琢磨，现实与虚构的界限到底在哪里？
One Saturday night, Aaron Etchler had all of his fellow 10-year-olds in the Sioux cabin completely worked up by telling them the story of Candyman. Candyman, if you know this story, appears and kills you if you say his name 10 times. Aaron said that a friend of his had died this way.
有一个周六晚上，亚伦·埃奇勒给苏族（Sioux）宿舍里所有10岁的孩子讲了“糖果人”（Candyman）的故事，把大家吓坏了。如果你知道这个故事，糖果人会在你念出他的名字10次后出现并杀死你。亚伦说他的一个朋友就是这样死的。
He said his friend died from Candyman.
他说他的朋友死于糖果人之手。
He was crying last night because of the Candyman.
他昨晚因为糖果人的事哭了。
I was this close to killing myself because it was so scary.
我当时差点吓死了，因为它太可怕了。
And that freaked me out, like hysterically.
这让我 hysterically（歇斯底里）地害怕。
We had to leave the bathroom light on last night because I keeped on saying, turn on the bathroom light on, man, I'm so scared.
昨晚我们不得不留着浴室的灯，因为我一直在说：“把灯打开，伙计，我太害怕了。”
We kept our light on the whole night because we were so scared.
我们整晚都开着灯，因为我们太害怕了。
What could be more fun than getting scared like that? Nearly all of them had trouble sleeping, so much trouble that they were not allowed to tell any scary stories Sunday night at lights out. So instead, they tried something else, an experiment. I joined them after dark, after evening activity, right before lights out, in their cabin.
还有什么比这种恐惧更有趣的呢？几乎所有人都睡不着觉，以至于周日晚上熄灯后他们被禁止再讲恐怖故事。所以，他们尝试了另一种东西，一个实验。天黑后，晚间活动结束，熄灯前，我加入了他们的行列。
Who's ready?
谁准备好了？
Let's do it.
开始吧。
OK, guys. Ready to be chantful.
好的，伙计们。准备好念咒语了。
Everybody in.
每个人都进来。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[杂乱的声音]
--Bloody Mary--
——血腥玛丽——
I'm Alex, and we're going to do a little seance over Bloody Mary. We're going to go into the bathroom. I think our whole cabin is going to because this is going to be a great time.
我是亚历克斯，我们要为“血腥玛丽”进行一次降神会。我们要进浴室。我想我们整个宿舍都要去，因为这会很有趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
What you're going to probably see is a bloody face when you say Bloody Mary 40 times.
当你念40遍“血腥玛丽”时，你可能会看到一张血淋淋的脸。
You'll see the bloody face of Bloody Mary.
你会看到血腥玛丽那张血淋淋的脸。
In the mirror?
在镜子里？
Yes. Face in the blood, very ugly.
是的。满脸是血，非常丑。
Bloody face.
血淋淋的脸。
It's going to be scary.
这会很吓人的。
I squeeze into the tiny bathroom with 12 10-year-old boys. Some of the boys hold their arms as if they're cradling a baby.
我挤进小小的浴室，里面有12个10岁的男孩。有些男孩抱着手臂，好像在怀里抱着个婴儿。
If you act like you have a baby in your hands, and you say Bloody Mary 50 times, then you'll have, actually, a dead baby in your hands.
如果你表现得好像手里抱着个婴儿，然后念50遍“血腥玛丽”，你手里真的会有一个死婴。
And why a baby?
为什么要个婴儿？
It's Bloody Mary's baby, they say. She threw it up in the air, and she didn't catch it in time, and it fell.
那是血腥玛丽的宝宝，他们说。她把它扔到空中，没有及时接住，它就掉下去了。
That's the story?
这就是故事？
Yeah.
是的。
It's called Blue Baby. It's called Blue--
它叫“蓝色宝宝”（Blue Baby）。它叫蓝——
Baby Blue. Not Blue Baby.
是“宝贝蓝”（Baby Blue）。不是“蓝色宝宝”。
It's time to do this Bloody Mary bloody thing. Turn off the lights.
现在是时候做那个血腥玛丽的事了。关灯。
Let's get scared. Ready? 1, 2--
我们来吓一吓吧。准备好了吗？1，2——
(CHANTING) Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary. Bloody--
（吟诵）血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。血腥——
They're 10. In a couple of years, there'll be cynics in the bunch, and they'll all be competing to prove they're too cool to believe in stuff like Bloody Mary. But for now, we all watch the mirror.
他们才10岁。再过几年，这群人里就会出现愤世嫉俗者，他们会争相证明自己太酷了，不相信“血腥玛丽”这类东西。但现在，我们都盯着镜子。
Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary. Bloody Mary.
血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。血腥玛丽。
Bloody Mary. Stop! Crap, it didn't-- how many times did you do it?
血腥玛丽。停！糟了，没出现——你们念了多少遍？
40 times.
40遍。
You have to do it 50--
你们得念50遍——
They're so ready to believe that when the face doesn't appear in the mirror, their first explanation is that maybe you need to chant 50 times, not 40. And then--
他们太想相信了，以至于镜子里没出现脸时，他们的第一个解释是也许需要念50遍，而不是40遍。然后——
Guys, why did you do that?
伙计们，你们为什么那么做？
I felt a baby in my hands.
我感觉到手里有个婴儿。
He felt a baby in his hands. It worked.
他感觉到手里有个婴儿。成功了。
I felt a baby in my hands.
我感觉到手里有个婴儿。
So do I. And you're supposed to go like this.
我也感觉到了。你们应该这样做。
So did it work?
所以成功了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It worked in a different way than we expected it to, but you felt Baby Blue in your hands.
它以一种不同于我们预期的方式成功了，但你确实感觉到了手里有“宝贝蓝”。
It took a while after that for them to settle into their beds. When I left half an hour later, it did not seem like anybody was going to be falling asleep very quickly.
之后过了好一阵子他们才安静下来躺进被窝。半小时后我离开时，似乎并没有人能很快入睡。
Notes on Camp three, You. Well, a few weeks ago, we invited your stories about camp. And you responded, so many of you, with so many great camp stories. Here is a selection.
笔记三：你们。几周前，我们邀请你们分享关于夏令营的故事。你们响应了，那么多人，分享了那么多棒极了的故事。这里有一些精选。
When I was five, my parents got divorced, and my father remarried the day after. In fact, he eloped to South Dakota because, in Minnesota, you had to wait six months between your divorce and remarriage. And then when I was eight, my mom died, and we were adopted by a nice, young couple, my sister and brother and I.
我五岁时，父母离婚了，父亲第二天就再婚了。事实上，他是私奔到南达科他州的，因为在明尼苏达州，离婚后再婚必须等待六个月。我八岁时，母亲去世了，我和姐姐、哥哥被一对年轻、友善的夫妇收养了。
And I remember one year, we went to a long weekend type of religious camp. It was sponsored through our church, but it had counselors there from a lot of different churches. And there was this one guy there that looked just like my dad. And I must have been, I don't know, nine and a half, 10. I was convinced that that was my father and that he had realized the error of his ways. And I had imagined that there must be some prohibition on him contacting the kids after he put them up for adoption, and I just thought this was his way of checking on us.
我记得有一年，我们去参加了一个长周末式的宗教夏令营。它是由我们教会赞助的，但有很多不同教会的辅导员。那里有个男人，长得和我爸爸一模一样。我当时肯定大概九岁半、十岁吧。我确信那就是我爸爸，他意识到自己的错误了。我想象着一定有什么规定禁止他在我们被收养后联系我们，我以为这就是他查看我们的方式。
And I would say things, like leading statements like, do you remember when I was little and you fixed my dolly, Peaches? Well, of course, he just looked at me like I was nuts. I mean, he must have thought, what an odd little girl. But I was sure. And I told my sister, Tracy, isn't that Dad? And she said, no, of course not. But I was sure. Somehow, it made me feel better, as strange as that seems. For that long weekend, that was my dad.
我会说一些引导性的句子，比如：“你还记得我小时候你帮我修好娃娃‘桃子’的时候吗？”当然，他只是像看疯子一样看着我。我是说，他一定在想：“这孩子真奇怪。”但我很确信。我告诉我的姐姐特蕾西：“那不是爸爸吗？”她说：“不，当然不是。”但我很确定。不知为何，这让我感觉好受些，尽管这看起来很奇怪。那个长周末，那就是我的爸爸。
My mother emigrated to the United States from Germany in the '50s, and her understanding of American culture and traditions wasn't always quite clear. And one of her confusions was about summer camp. She knew that kids should go to summer camp, but she didn't realize that it usually involved 24-hour adult supervision. So one week, she drove us up to a campground on the coast of Malibu and set us up in this tent and left us some groceries, and then she drove home to go back to work.
我母亲在50年代从德国移民到美国，她对美国文化和传统的理解并不总是很清晰。她困惑的一点是关于夏令营。她知道孩子们应该去夏令营，但她没意识到那通常需要24小时的成人监督。所以有一天，她开车把我们送到马里布海岸的一个露营地，把我们安顿在帐篷里，留了一些杂货，然后就开车回家回去工作了。
And so I was left in charge of my brothers, and I was 12 and my brothers were 10 and 7. And we were at summer camp. We played in the ocean. We played in the little stream that ran by our campsite. We picked things and tried to figure out whether they were edible. And the only problem that we had, really, was that we had to keep it a secret that our parents weren't there, and this involved lots of stealth and subterfuge. We would notice that campers were looking over in our direction at some point and kind of wondering where our parents were.
所以我就负责照顾我的兄弟们，我当时12岁，他们分别是10岁和7岁。我们就在夏令营里。我们在海里玩。我们在营地旁边的小溪里玩。我们采摘东西，试图弄清楚它们是否能吃。我们唯一的问题是，我们必须保守父母不在身边的秘密，这涉及大量的伪装和欺骗。有时我们会注意到其他营员朝我们这边看，好像在奇怪我们的父母在哪。
So in the morning, when we got ready to go to the beach, I would unzip the tent and yell into the tent, bye, Mom, bye, Dad. We're going to the beach, see you later and hope that we'd be overheard doing this. And my brothers kind of picked up on this, so one of them, when he would see a man in a car driving out of the campground, if he was alone, he would yell after him, bye, Dad. Don't forget the Popsicles, as if the guy in the car were going to get us some groceries. We were pretty obsessed with groceries.
所以早上我们要去海滩时，我会拉开帐篷拉链，大喊道：“再见，妈妈，再见，爸爸。我们要去海滩了，待会儿见。”希望有人能听到。我的弟弟们学得很快，所以当其中一个看到一个男人开车离开营地时，如果他是一个人，他就会追着大喊：“再见，爸爸！别忘了买冰棒！”好像开车那人要帮我们去买杂货似的。我们真的很执着于杂货。
And a week later, my mom came back. We had called her and told her how much we hated summer camp. And she thought that we were extremely spoiled because we didn't appreciate this great outdoor experience that was obviously a big part of American life.
一周后，我妈妈回来了。我们给她打过电话，说我们多讨厌夏令营。她认为我们非常被宠坏了，因为我们不懂得欣赏这种显然是美国生活重要部分的伟大户外体验。
The first year I went, I was 10 years old. And that was a kind of a fluke because my parents were very committed left-wingers, and they wouldn't let me join the Girl Scouts because my mother called them a bunch of little brown shirts. And they wouldn't let me go to a fashionable summer camp because they didn't believe in fashion. So my father asked a friend where his kids went, and his kids went to this very left-wing, Zionist camp. And so they got me in.
我第一年去的时候是10岁。那纯属偶然，因为我的父母是坚定的左翼分子，他们不让我参加女童子军，因为我母亲称她们是一群“小棕衫军”。他们也不让我去那种时尚的夏令营，因为他们不相信时尚。所以我父亲问一个朋友他的孩子去哪，他孩子去的是一个非常左翼的锡安主义夏令营。所以他们把我送进去了。
But we had, one day at lunchtime, a rock came through the window of the dining hall. And it landed in my soup, and there was a note wrapped around the rock. And it said, we don't want no Jew camps in Wisconsin. And so, of course, being a highly political group of people, they got together, and they had discussions, and they went on and on. And they posted guards. We had to paint our faces black so we wouldn't show up at night, and so on.
但有一天午餐时，一块石头穿过食堂窗户扔了进来，落在了我的汤里。石头上包着一张纸条，上面写着：“我们不想要威斯康星州有任何犹太夏令营。”当然，作为一群高度政治化的群体，他们聚在一起，进行了讨论，没完没了。他们还派了守卫。我们不得不把脸涂黑，这样晚上就不会被发现，诸如此类。
And so a bunch of us were sitting in the dining hall, and somebody said, look, out on the lawn. And there was this large cross burning out on the lawn of the campgrounds. And these people came in, and they were all wearing white sheets, and they had these white things over their heads like pillowcases. And they made us all go outside, and there was another guy in a white sheet and a white pillowcase riding up and down on a horse.
后来，我们一群人坐在食堂里，有人说：“看，草坪外面。”草坪上正在燃烧一个巨大的十字架。这些人走了进来，都穿着白袍，头上蒙着像枕套一样的白色东西。他们强迫我们所有人都到外面去，还有一个穿白袍蒙枕套的人骑着马走来走去。
And they started to yell at us that they wanted the lousy Jews out of Wisconsin and that they didn't want no Jew camps in Wisconsin. And they said, don't bother trying to call the authorities because in this neck of the woods, we are the authorities. And everybody was just petrified.
他们开始大喊，要让这些可恶的犹太人滚出威斯康星州，他们不想要威斯康星州有任何犹太夏令营。他们说：“别费劲报警了，因为在这一带，我们就是法律。”每个人都吓坏了。
And we all stood around, shaking in our boots, and all of a sudden, one of the counselors said, I'm an American citizen. You can't treat me like this. So two of the guys in sheets grabbed him by the arms and marched him away. And another counselor said, I'm an American citizen. You can't treat us like this.
我们站在那里，吓得发抖。突然，一个辅导员说：“我是美国公民。你们不能这样对待我。”于是两个穿白袍的家伙抓住他的胳膊把他带走了。另一个辅导员说：“我是美国公民。你们不能这样对待我们。”
And pretty soon, all the counselors were being marched away, and we were all left there. And I got really frightened. So I went, I'm an American citizen too. And somebody came over in a white sheet and took me down towards the beach. And as he was marching me down to the beach, he said to me, Adina, couldn't you have kept your big mouth shut? And it was all a political lesson that we were supposed to be learning.
很快，所有的辅导员都被带走了，我们剩下的人被留在那里。我真的被吓坏了，所以我就喊：“我也是美国公民！”有人穿着白袍走过来，把我带向海滩。当他把我押向海滩时，他对我说：“阿迪娜，你就不能闭上你的大嘴吗？”这一切原来是我们应该学习的一堂政治课。
Anyway, I was seven, and it was church camp. And several men dressed in black holding machine guns entered the chapel at different areas. They immediately tied the hands of the four pastors on stage and held a gun on the main pastor.
总之，我七岁时参加了教会夏令营。几个身穿黑衣、手持机枪的男人从不同地方进入礼拜堂。他们立即捆绑了台上的四位牧师，并用枪指着主牧师。
I think as soon as the man said, if you're a Christian, stand up, the devoted stood, and the rest just ran off. And there were kids running all over the woods. And as we walked to our cabin, we saw counselors with flashlights and bullhorns proclaiming it was only a play. We heard kids yelling and cursing and crying, and it was pretty bad.
我想那个人一说“如果你是基督徒，就站起来”，虔诚的人就站起来了，剩下的就跑了。树林里到处都是奔跑的孩子。当我们走到宿舍时，我们看到辅导员拿着手电筒和扩音器宣布这只是一场戏。我们听到孩子们在大喊大叫、咒骂和哭泣，那真的很糟糕。
Thanks to everybody who called. Thanks to everybody who wrote.
感谢每一位致电和写信的朋友。
Note number four, Ritual. Down by the lake, some of the Bryn Mawr girls explained it all to me. Every year it's the same-- same songs, same ceremonies. There's Circle and Olympic Days. There's Color Days. There's Mohawk privileges and cabin nights. And there's the dance where the girls choose a boy who they'll marry for one day. And there's the powwow.
笔记四：仪式。在湖边，一些布林莫尔（Bryn Mawr）的女孩向我解释了这一切。每年都一样——同样的歌，同样的仪式。有“圆圈日”和“奥运会日”。有“色彩日”。有“莫霍克特权”和“宿舍之夜”。还有舞会，女孩们会选一个男孩作为一天的“伴侣”。还有部落聚会。
Last year, first session, they took powwow away from us because it was politically incorrect or something. And we were all really upset because powwow was one of our biggest camp traditions, because we have a little song or whatever in the beginning. And it's--
去年第一期，他们取消了部落聚会，因为这在政治上不正确什么的。我们都很难过，因为部落聚会是我们最大的夏令营传统之一，我们在开头有一首小歌之类的。而且它——
[SINGING CHANT]
[唱歌呼喊]
And you do different hand motions and everything to it, and it's really fun. And then you challenge other teams. It's fun. But then--
而且你还要配合做不同的手势，真的很有趣。然后你要向其他队伍挑战。很有趣。但是后来——
Before you continue, can I just say that it's really interesting that you can't even tell the story without suddenly bursting into song.
在你继续之前，我可以说，你甚至不能在不突然唱起来的情况下讲完这个故事，这真的很奇妙。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Our camp sings a lot.
我们的夏令营唱很多歌。
Besides the singing, powwow includes a talent competition. One girl, her talent-- she crosses her eyes.
除了唱歌，部落聚会还包括才艺比赛。一个女孩，她的才艺是——她能把眼睛对在一起。
And Jolie can, like, snap her belly button.
朱莉还能把肚脐弹响。
Aw, I'm wearing a bathing suit.
哎呀，我穿着泳衣。
I can sing all the vowels in "Twinkle, Twinkle, Little Star." And you just do weird talents, and you challenge other teams.
我能用《小星星》的所有元音唱歌。你就是表演一些奇怪的才艺，然后向其他队伍挑战。
At the end, if your team is the best, you get a peace feather.
最后，如果你们队是最棒的，你们会得到一根和平羽毛。
The reason it got taken away last year was because a lot of the counselors felt that it was politically incorrect because the speeches that the Indians make are derogatory towards Native American culture, if you look at it that way.
去年它被取消的原因是很多辅导员觉得在政治上不正确，因为印第安人的演讲如果从那个角度看，是对美洲原住民文化的一种贬低。
I asked for examples. A few of the girls hold their palms up in the air and say, how. They launch into these fake, pidgin English sentences where they drop lots of verbs and add "um" to the ends of the words.
我要求举例。几个女孩举起手掌，说道：“How”（印第安语问候）。她们开始用这种虚假的、皮钦语式的英语句子，去掉很多动词，在单词后面加“um”。
We go to Lake-um of the Woods-um Camp-um.
我们要去森林-um湖-um夏令营-um。
Live-um in Vassar East-um. I teach-um camper naps how to walk-um on water-um. Inside jokes [INAUDIBLE] put into with adding stuff that Indians or whatever.
住在瓦萨-um东区。我教-um露营者如何走-um在水-um上。把内部笑话（听不清）加上印第安人之类的东西。
They're just so funny that it's not even-- no one even really thinks about it like that.
它们太搞笑了，以至于人们甚至不会那样去想。
Yeah.
是啊。
In fact, fake Indianness has been a part of camping in America since organized camping began a century ago. One of the cofounders of the Boy Scouts of America ran a camp in 1901 in which he organized boys into a make-believe tribe called the Sinaways. The Red Man is the apostle of outdoor life, he wrote back then. His example and precept are what young America needs today, above any other ethical teaching-- Indianness and a real connection to nature, an appreciation for all that was being lost with industrialization and urbanization.
事实上，伪印第安文化自一个世纪前有组织的露营活动开始以来，就一直是美国露营活动的一部分。美国童子军的一位联合创始人于1901年举办了一个夏令营，他将男孩们组织成一个名为“Sinaways”的虚构部落。“红人是户外生活的使徒，”他当时写道。他的榜样和准则是当今美国青少年最需要的，远超过任何其他道德教化——印第安文化和与自然的真正联结，以及对工业化和城市化过程中正在丧失的一切的欣赏。
Just one generation after Custer's Last Stand, fake Indianness was an integral part of the early Boy Scouts and Girl Scouts organizations in this country. By 1910, camps with names like Camp Minnewawa, Camp Miramichi, Camp Pokanoket were springing up everywhere for middle-class and upper-class children. It is still a big part of camping all across America. And after a year without powwow, Camp Lake of the Woods brought the powwow back.
就在卡斯特最后之战的一代之后，伪印第安文化就已成为美国早期童子军和女童子军组织不可或缺的一部分。到1910年，像“Minnewawa”、“Miramichi”、“Pokanoket”这样名字的夏令营在全国各地如雨后春笋般为中产阶级和上层阶级子女开设。它至今仍是美国各地夏令营的重要组成部分。在经历了一年没有部落聚会后，森林湖夏令营又把部落聚会带回来了。
Most of this simply has to do with tradition. The special songs and ceremonies are a part of so many American camps, and it's not just because they're fun. A camp director in Wisconsin told us as we were putting together today's program that, financially, you cannot run a camp without lots of repeat customers. These traditions bring kids back year after year. You have the kids singing constantly about their loyalty to their cabinmates and their camp. You let them know about all the extra rights and privileges and honors that they're going to get if they return as older campers.
这大部分只是为了传统。特殊的歌曲和仪式是许多美国夏令营的一部分，这不仅仅是因为它们有趣。威斯康星州的一位夏令营主管在我们要准备今天的节目时告诉我们，从财务上讲，没有大量的回头客是无法经营夏令营的。这些传统让孩子们年复一年地回来。你让孩子们不断唱着对宿舍伙伴和夏令营的忠诚。你让他们知道，如果他们以资深营员的身份回来，将会获得所有额外的权利、特权和荣誉。
It is part of making the business run. And in addition, it's part of what makes camp thrilling. It is using all of the stagecraft that all the world's religions have always used, the ceremonies, the chanting, the repeated words, the official honors and offices, but for an entirely secular purpose-- to thrill children, to make them feel part of something big and special.
这是经营生意的一部分。此外，这也是夏令营令人兴奋的原因之一。它运用了世界各宗教一直使用的所有舞台艺术——仪式、吟诵、重复的词语、官方的荣誉和职位——但却是为了一个完全世俗的目的——去震撼孩子们，让他们觉得自己属于某个宏大而特别的事物。
I think it's a really important part of camp. I mean, I personally-- I like the traditions because you know what's going to happen, and you can trust things that--
我觉得这是夏令营非常重要的一部分。我的意思是，我个人——我喜欢这些传统，因为你知道会发生什么，你可以信任这些事情——
You expect it.
你有所期待。
Yeah.
是的。
I come back for the traditions. I expect everything to be here the way it was last year because that's the reason I come back. If everything changed, I don't think I would like it anymore.
我回来就是为了这些传统。我期待一切都在这里，像去年一样，因为这就是我回来的原因。如果一切都变了，我想我就不会再喜欢它了。
Well, coming up, war. What is it good for? Answers. Also, the second mention of the Israeli Army in one radio show. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
好了，接下来是战争。它有什么用？答案。此外，这是一期广播节目中第二次提到以色列军队。节目将在公共广播国际频道的下一时段继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Notes on Camp-- summer camp. A lot of the pleasure of being in camp is the pleasure of being part of this team, this group that you just feel loyal to, which also happens to be one of the pleasures of being in the military, since ancient times.
这是《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“夏令营笔记”——暑期夏令营。在夏令营中，很大一部分乐趣在于成为这个团队的一员，这个让你感到忠诚的群体，而这也是自古以来参加军队的乐趣之一。
Well, Adam Davidson is half Israeli, grew up in America. And when he was 15, he went to a camp run by the Israeli Army in Israel on their own training facilities. The campers ran the same drills. They shot M16s. It was all designed to convince these American Jews to move to Israel and join the Israeli Army someday.
亚当·戴维森有一半以色列血统，在美国长大。15岁时，他去了一个由以色列军队在以色列自己的训练设施中举办的夏令营。营员们进行同样的演习，射击M16步枪。所有这一切都是为了说服这些美国犹太人搬到以色列，并在未来加入以色列军队。
It's so exciting because you really feel-- I mean, you know-- that at that age, when you're 15, and you're in Israeli Army summer camp, there is no one in the history of the world who is cooler than an elite army unit soldier. I loved the fact that we would go to the bathroom, and the toilets wouldn't have a seat because that's a place where terrorists could put a bomb. And it just felt so macho crouching on top of the seat and showering in this freezing cold water. Because what? (IN ISRAELI ACCENT) A Sayeret Matkal would need hot water? Why?
这太令人兴奋了，因为你真的感觉到——你知道——在那个15岁的年纪，当你身处以色列军队夏令营时，世界上没有任何人比精英部队的士兵更酷。我喜欢这样的事实：我们去洗手间时，厕所没有座圈，因为那是恐怖分子可能放置炸弹的地方。蹲在座圈上，在冰冷的水中淋浴，感觉真棒。因为什么？（用以色列口音）总参谋部侦察队（Sayeret Matkal）的人需要热水吗？为什么？
Now for me, for the first few weeks, what was tough about this was that I was really a nobody there, and I'd always be bringing up the rear. I'd always be kind of slow. And I wasn't showing myself to be macho even though there were so many opportunities in a given day to prove yourself macho.
对我来说，最初的几周，最难受的是我在那儿真是个无名小卒，总是拖后腿。我总是慢吞吞的。即使每天都有那么多机会证明自己很硬汉，但我还是没表现出来。
I mean, we were always, for no apparent reason, running like crazy from one tree to another tree, or up some mountain every few minutes, or something you could be the best at. And I was never the best.
我的意思是，我们总是无缘无故地像疯了一样从一棵树跑到另一棵树，或者每隔几分钟就爬上一座山，或者是某些你可以表现得最好的事情。但我从来不是最强的。
But all of this changed. My geek status was completely transformed. One night, the different units would put on plays, and we were supposed to do take-offs of fairy tales. And this was some kind of a competition. There was voting over who did the best job.
但这一切都变了。我的极客身份彻底改变了。一天晚上，不同的单元要表演戏剧，我们要做童话故事的模仿表演。这是一场比赛。大家投票决定谁做得最好。
So my group, [INAUDIBLE], our fairy tale was Steve White and the Seven Dwarfs. And I would be Steve White, this fabulous gay man who lives with these seven dwarfs, and the prince who comes to rescue me would be Rambo.
所以我们组（听不清），我们的童话故事是《史蒂夫·怀特和七个小矮人》。我会扮演史蒂夫·怀特，这个和七个小矮人住在一起的、绝妙的男同性恋，而来救我的王子则是兰博。
This was one of those moments where I just knew that I was in the zone. I was in my element. I mean, I was from Greenwich Village. I had been an actor all through my childhood. My dad was an actor.
这是我感觉到自己进入状态的时刻之一。我找到了自己的元素。我是格林威治村人。我整个童年都在演戏。我爸爸是个演员。
But more than that, there's a way that Americans can be very free that Israelis can't be, precisely because they have to be macho. And no matter what they're doing, even if they're mocking themselves, they have to maintain that studliness. And I had no obligations in that area.
但更重要的是，美国人有一种以色列人无法拥有的自由，正是因为他们必须保持硬汉形象。无论他们在做什么，即使是在嘲笑自己，他们也必须保持那种男子气概。而我在那方面没有任何包袱。
I dressed myself just-- I tried not to be too outrageous, but I had to be kind of outrageous for them to get it. So a little bit of rouge, a little bit of eyeliner, my hair kind of slicked back with mousse, and sort of ridiculously short shorts.
我把自己打扮得——我尽量不让自己太出格，但我必须有点出格他们才能懂。所以一点胭脂，一点眼线，用摩丝把头发向后抹，还有短得离谱的短裤。
And so I'm lying there, and I hear a knock on the door. And I just stand up, and I remember the entire crowd is howling, just howling. And I just do the most awful, mincing gay voice, just who is it?
我躺在那里，听到敲门声。我站起来，记得全场都在尖叫，简直是尖叫。我用最糟糕、最做作的男同声音说：“是谁？”
And my friend, who was a skinhead from Toronto whose parents happened to be Israeli, says, it's Rambo. And I say, oh, Rambo, you sexy beast. And everyone is freaking out, just laughing like mad, like maniacs. And of course, throughout it all, I'm making jokes about the camp members themselves, like saying, oh, I think Commander Oloney is just the thing. And everything I say, the entire crowd is just with me, is just laughing hysterically.
我的朋友，那个父母恰好是以色列人的多伦多光头党，说：“是兰博。”我说：“噢，兰博，你这性感野兽。”所有人都在发疯，简直像疯子一样狂笑。当然，全程我都在拿夏令营成员自己开玩笑，比如：“哦，我觉得奥洛尼指挥官简直棒极了。”我说的每一句话，全场都跟我一起，歇斯底里地笑着。
And what happens to Snow White-- to Steve White-- I eat the apple, I pass out, and I need to be resuscitated. So Rambo comes to kiss me, and what we had worked out is he put his hand in front of his mouth, and I put my hand in front of my mouth, and we just touched hands. And we'r kissing our mouths, but from a distance, it looks like we're making out.
白雪公主——史蒂夫·怀特——发生了什么呢？我吃了苹果，昏了过去，需要人工呼吸。于是兰博来吻我，我们商量好的是他把手挡在嘴前，我也把手挡在嘴前，我们只是碰了碰手。我们吻着彼此的嘴，但从远处看，就像是在亲热。
And I mean, at this point, the camp, they're standing up, they're howling. I mean, I have transgressed every boundary that the Israeli man sets for himself, and they are loving the other side.
此时此刻，营地里的伙伴们站起来尖叫。我的意思是，我跨越了以色列男人为自己设定的每一个界限，而他们爱死了这一面。
And from that point on, I was no longer the unknown American bringing up the rear of the obstacle course. I was like a movie star. I mean, everyone-- the Israeli guys, particularly the macho-est, toughest Israeli guys, constantly wanted to do this make out thing where we put our hands over our mouths and make out.
从那以后，我不再是那个在障碍赛中拖后腿的无名美国人。我简直像个电影明星。我的意思是，每个人——以色列男孩们，尤其是那些最硬汉、最坚强的以色列男孩——不断地想要玩这种我们把手放在嘴上亲热的游戏。
We'd be relaxing after some really long hike in the Negev Desert or something, and Nehtyu or Shaoul or whatever would come up to me and say, (IN ISRAELI ACCENT) it's very funny the way you do this make out thing. Show me do it. Let's do it.
我们在内盖夫沙漠长途跋涉后放松时，内图或沙乌尔之类的家伙会走过来对我说：（用以色列口音）“你玩这种亲热游戏的方式很有趣。表演给我看。我们来玩吧。”
And the first few times I would do it. I mean, I guess part of me was flattered that, like, the macho future Sayeret Matkal guys were into me in any way. But after a while, it was just so weird. I'd just be like, look, Shaoul, I'm just not going to do that. I don't do that anymore. I'm just not going to do it. And they'd be like, (IN ISRAELI ACCENT) why not? Do it. It's very funny, that's all. It's not for anything, but just the funny.
最初几次我确实做了。我想有一部分是因为被这些硬汉、未来的总参谋部侦察队成员以任何方式关注而受宠若惊。但过了一会儿，这真是太奇怪了。我就说：“看，沙乌尔，我不想玩那个了。我不再那样做了。我不干了。”他们就会说：（用以色列口音）“为什么不？做吧。很有趣，就是这样。没别的，就是好玩。”
Now, I've been to plenty of camps, and in every camp, you're somehow a part of a team. I remember in Boy Scout camp when I was at horse riding camp, it was the people who rode horses in the morning versus the people who rode horses in the afternoon. And I just loved my guys, and I would look in the lunchroom at the other bunk and just-- I just didn't understand how you could even live in that bunk.
我去过很多夏令营，在每个夏令营里，你都以某种方式成为团队的一部分。我记得在骑马夏令营时，是早上骑马的人和下午骑马的人之间的对抗。我深爱我的伙计们，在食堂里看到另一个宿舍的人，我就是——我就是不理解你怎么能住在那个宿舍里。
But Israeli Army summer camp is the purest distillation I've ever seen of this joy in being a part of the group. Every week, I would do things that I wouldn't have thought I could possibly do, and that was so incredible. And I knew that was because of the group. I knew that was giving me the force. And there was never a moment where I had to ask myself, can I do it? It was just, we're doing this. [INAUDIBLE] is going to do this.
但以色列军队夏令营是我见过的关于“融入集体”这种快乐最纯粹的升华。每周，我都会做一些我以为自己根本不可能做到的事情，那真是太不可思议了。我知道那是群体赋予我的力量。从来没有一个时刻我不得不问自己：“我能做到吗？”只是“我们正在做这件事”。（听不清）将要做这件事。
Adam Davidson is now a member of our Planet Money team. Though he intended to join the Israeli Army when he was 15, it never worked out.
亚当·戴维森现在是我们《星球金钱》（Planet Money）团队的成员。虽然他15岁时打算加入以色列军队，但最终没能成行。
Note on Camp number six, Color Days. It is impossible to overstate what a big deal Color Days is at the camp in Michigan Julie Snyder and I visited. It is like any Color Wars at any camp, except that it's three days, and once you're assigned a team-- a Blue team or a White team for girls, Black or Red for boys-- you will stay on that team all your years at camp. There are legacies. Your brothers and sisters will be on the same team as you are.
夏令营笔记六：色彩日。无论如何强调“色彩日”在我们参观的密歇根州这个夏令营里的重要性都不为过。它就像任何夏令营的“色彩大战”，除了它持续三天。一旦你被分配到一个队——女孩是蓝队或白队，男孩是黑队或红队——你在夏令营的所有岁月里都将留在这个队。这里有传承。你的兄弟姐妹将和你在同一个队。
Being named a captain of the Color Days teams is considered such a big deal that many older campers can name all the captains of all their Color Day teams going back years. Two girls and two boys are named as captain each year for each team. Only campers from the oldest bunks can be captain. Bryn Mawr is for girls, Mohawks and Blackhawks for boys.
被任命为“色彩日”队的队长被视为一件大事，以至于许多资深营员能叫出多年来他们所有色彩日队伍的队长名字。每年每个队有两名女孩和两名男孩被任命为队长。只有年龄最大的宿舍的营员才能当队长。布林莫尔是给女生的，莫霍克和黑鹰是给男生的。
Counselors who were once named as captains, if you talk to them about it, they get all choked up when they tell you about the moment they were chosen. Even Dayna Hardin, the 29-year-old owner of the camp, went into this long explanation of the ceremony with me at one point, her voice cracking, ending with--
曾经当过队长的辅导员，如果你和他们聊这个，当他们向你讲述被选中的那一刻时，他们会哽咽。甚至夏令营的拥有者、29岁的戴娜·哈丁，有一次也和我详细解释了这个仪式，她的声音颤抖着，最后说道——
Oh, I'm almost in tears right now. [LAUGHS] I really am, because, I mean, it was the biggest honor in my life.
噢，我现在快要流泪了。[笑] 我真的是，因为，我的意思是，这是我一生中最大的荣誉。
Julie Snyder watched the girls Color Days this year.
朱莉·斯奈德观看了今年女孩们的色彩日。
Just to give you a sense of the intensity of Color Days, a month before it all begins, an 11-year-old Blue team member tells me Color Days isn't all that competitive. I mean, she'd talk to a girl on the White team and everything. And all I could think was, if you have to say something like that, you know there's going to be trouble. The speculation about who will get the honor of being captain of the Color Days team, the biggest honor at camp, is so intense that, weeks before Color Days begins, Lindsay Sayowitz and some friends in Bryn Mawr East decide to consult Lindsay's Ouija board.
为了让你们感受一下色彩日的紧张程度，在比赛开始前一个月，一个11岁的蓝队成员告诉我色彩日并不那么有竞争性。我是说，她会和白队的女孩说话什么的。而我所想的只是：如果你不得不说出这种话，你知道准会有麻烦。关于谁能获得“色彩日”队长的荣誉——这是夏令营最大的荣誉——的猜测非常激烈，以至于在色彩日开始前几周，琳赛·萨约维茨和布林莫尔东宿舍的一些朋友决定求助于琳赛的“通灵板”（Ouija board）。
Is anyone here?
有人在这吗？
Hello? Who is this? B-L-A-I-R. Blair.
你好？这是谁？B-L-A-I-R。布莱尔。
Our old friend.
我们的老朋友。
Blair? We talk to her a lot. OK.
布莱尔？我们经常跟她谈。好的。
Do you know who the Color Days captains are for girls? Could you name one of them? OK.
你知道女孩们的色彩日队长是谁吗？你能说出一个名字吗？好的。
A-L-I-S-S-A. Alissa. Alissa Strom.
A-L-I-S-S-A。艾丽莎。艾丽莎·斯特罗姆。
She'll get it, I bet.
我敢打赌她会当选。
Everyone thinks Alissa's a shoe-in. And the Ouija board also picked Jamie Stream, another favorite, and Lindsay Sayowitz, who, coincidentally, had her hands on the Ouija pointer at the time.
每个人都认为艾丽莎稳操胜券。通灵板还选出了杰米·斯特里姆（另一个热门人选），以及当时正好把手放在通灵板指针上的琳赛·萨约维茨。
Two weeks later, in the middle of the night, all the girls' counselors snake through the cabin area with lit kerosene torches and wake up the girls for the opening ceremonies of Color Days 1998.
两周后的午夜，所有女辅导员带着点燃的煤油火把，在宿舍区蜿蜒穿过，唤醒女孩们参加1998年色彩日的开幕仪式。
Girls, it's time to wake up. Everybody up out of bed. Get a pair of pants on, shoes on. Wake up, [INAUDIBLE].
姑娘们，起床时间到了。大家都起床。穿上裤子，穿上鞋。醒醒，（听不清）。
Little girls stumble out onto the sidewalks, rubbing their eyes, wearing mismatched shoes and looking confused. Across the way, the Bryn Mawr girls have never even gone to sleep, anticipating this moment when they find out which one of them will be named Color Days captain. They stand with their faces pressed up to the screen door of their cabin, holding hands and silently crying. Counselors with torches lead 120 girls. They march down to the lakefront and surround an enormous bonfire 10 feet high. It looks like some cross between a debutante ball and a Klan rally.
小女孩们揉着眼睛跌跌撞撞地走到人行道上，穿着不配套的鞋子，看起来很困惑。在另一边，布林莫尔的女孩们甚至根本没睡，期待着这一刻，找出她们中谁将被任命为色彩日队长。她们脸贴着宿舍的纱门，手拉手无声地哭泣。带着火把的辅导员领着120名女孩。她们行进到湖边，环绕着一个10英尺高的巨大篝火。看起来既像一场名媛舞会，又像一场三K党集会。
We are here tonight to usher in our three days of competition known as Color Days. I call forth the first spirit. Do you hear me, O spirit? Come forth and tell us who you are and why you are here.
我们今晚在此迎接为期三天的“色彩日”比赛。我召唤第一个精神。你听到了吗，噢，精神？出来告诉我们你是谁，为什么在这里。
Like a summer stock Grecian play, one of the counselors dressed in a white toga comes out of the forest and stands behind the fire.
像一场暑期希腊戏剧一样，一名穿着白色托加长袍的辅导员从森林中走出，站在火堆后。
I am the spirit of the white. I represent the clouds of a summer's day, white caps in the water, and the dove of peace and purity.
我是白色的精神。我代表夏日的云朵、水中的白浪，以及和平与纯洁的鸽子。
What is the message you bring, O white spirit?
你带来了什么信息，噢，白色精神？
It is a difficult thought to convey, but rich in meaning in every way. One can't find peace in a world of dream. Each person is a fraction, a part of the team. We have no choice, everyone must belong. If no one is weak, can the team be strong?
这是一个难以传达的思想，但在各方面都意义深远。人在梦中找不到平静。每个人都是一个分数，队伍的一部分。我们别无选择，每个人都必须归属。如果没人软弱，队伍会强大吗？
I call forth the next spirit. Do you hear me, O spirit?
我召唤下一个精神。你听到了吗，噢，精神？
The spirit for the Blue team, another counselor in a toga, appears before the fire and talks about blue and blueness. Candles are lit, and the girls vow to abide by the camp's seven virtues during Color Days. Those virtues? Friendship, determination, sportsmanship, tolerance, enthusiasm, patience, and unity.
蓝队的精神，另一位穿着长袍的辅导员出现在火前，讲述着蓝色与蓝意。蜡烛点亮，女孩们发誓在色彩日期间遵守夏令营的七大美德。这些美德是？友谊、决心、体育精神、宽容、热情、耐心和团结。
In order that you may have time to consider carefully the meaning of these next few days, we ask that you now take a vow of silence. Please repeat after me. I will be silent.
为了让你们有时间仔细考虑接下来几天意味着什么，我们现在请你们保持沉默。请跟我重复。我会保持沉默。
I will be silent.
我会保持沉默。
Finally, the camp director, Dayna, picks up four whistles, two on a white string and two on blue. This is the moment everyone's been waiting for and guessing about, the moment Dayna remembers so well from 16 years ago when she was at Bryn Mawr. She walks behind all the girls to the last row, where the Bryn Mawr sit, and silently places the necklaces over the heads of the girls selected to be the captains of Color Days 1998.
最后，夏令营主管戴娜拿起了四个哨子，两个系在白绳上，两个系在蓝绳上。这是每个人都在等待和猜测的时刻，戴娜16年前在布林莫尔时还记得如此深刻的时刻。她走到所有女孩身后的最后一排，也就是布林莫尔女孩坐的地方，无声地将项链戴在被选为1998年色彩日队长的女孩们头上。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
The chosen girls stand up, sob, and cling to each other. The other girls stay seated, sob, and cling to each other. It turns out the Ouija board was only right about one of the captains, Lindsay Segenreich. Alissa and Jamie looked shocked and heartbroken. There's so much crying, some of the girls can barely walk straight as they stumble back to their cabins after the ceremony. Because of the vow of silence, there are lots of sniffles, gasps, and blowing noses. Color Days hasn't even started yet.
被选中的女孩们站起来，啜泣着，紧紧抱在一起。其他女孩坐在原地，啜泣着，紧紧抱在一起。事实证明，通灵板只猜对了一名队长，琳赛·塞根赖希。艾丽莎和杰米看起来既震惊又心碎。现场哭声一片，有些女孩在仪式后跌跌撞撞回宿舍时几乎走不直路。由于誓言，到处都是抽泣、喘息和擦鼻子的声音。色彩日甚至还没开始呢。
OK, for those who don't know yet, I'm Jamie.
好了，对于那些还不知道的人，我是杰米。
I'm Lindsey.
我是琳赛。
I'm Beth.
我是贝丝。
And we have an awesome team. I'm so excited.
我们有一个很棒的团队。我太兴奋了。
It's the next morning, and the White team has gathered for their first team meeting. The veteran campers are dressed entirely in white-- white shoes, shirts, socks, bandannas. Their faces are painted white. Their hair is painted white. Lindsay and Jamie, the White team captains, are in charge of organizing all the girls, raising their spirits and motivating the team. But it's difficult to hold your first pep rally within the confines of a vow of silence. Under the vow, only team captains are allowed to talk.
第二天早上，白队集合开第一次队会。老营员们全身上下都穿着白色——白鞋、白衬衫、白袜、白头巾。她们的脸被涂成白色。她们的头发被涂成白色。白队的队长琳赛和杰米负责组织所有女孩，鼓舞士气，激励队伍。但在誓言的约束下举行第一次动员大会很困难。根据誓言，只有队长允许说话。
OK, are you guys excited? Just nod your head.
好了，你们兴奋吗？点点头就好。
Just like that.
就这样。
After the flag raising on the first morning, the vow of silence is lifted. And then you realize why it was instituted in the first place. What follows are three days of solid wall-of-sound screaming. The girls cheer at the individual and team competitions. They cheer while standing around and waiting for their events to begin. They cheer on the way to the mess hall, they cheer outside the mess hall, and they cheer on the way back from the mess hall. They have constant team meetings where they talk about the importance of cheering.
第一天早上升旗后，誓言解除了。然后你就会明白为什么当初要设立这个。接下来的三天是持续的“音墙”式尖叫。女孩们为个人和团体比赛加油。她们在站着等待比赛开始时加油。她们在去食堂的路上加油，在食堂外加油，在从食堂回来的路上加油。她们有不断的队会，讨论加油的重要性。
You guys, cheering tonight is the most important night to cheer. That's why--
你们这些家伙，今晚的加油是最重要的。所以——
Cheer so loud. You guys, it is not normal if you don't lose your voices.
喊大声点。如果你们没喊哑嗓子，那就不正常。
White team, listen! This is really important.
白队，听着！这真的很重要。
This is really important, you guys. Really important.
这真的很重要，你们这些家伙。非常重要。
Trying your best is the most important thing right now.
尽力而为现在是最重要的事。
You run your butt over here as fast as you can because it is so important that you guys don't miss any of our meetings.
赶快跑过来，因为你们错过我们的会议是很重要的事。
[CROWD CHANTING AND CHEERING]
[人群呼喊和欢呼]
But some of the girls, the older girls, are having a hard time cheering.
但有些女孩，大一点的女孩，加油加油很吃力。
It is really hard to get in on it, because I'm telling people to be louder because I know they're not being loud enough, but yet, I can't do it myself.
真的很难加入进去，因为我告诉大家要大声点，因为我知道她们没够大声，但我自己却做不到。
Lexie is on the White team. She's a Bryn Mawr, was eligible to be a Color Days captain, and spent the last night crying. Because if being chosen for Color Days captain means you're a leader, an intelligent and caring person who looks out for other people, what does it mean if you're not chosen?
莱克西在白队。她是布林莫尔人，有资格成为色彩日队长，昨晚哭了一宿。因为如果被选为色彩日队长意味着你是一个领导者、一个关心他人且聪明的孩子，那么如果不被选上意味着什么？
I didn't expect it, but I really, really wanted captain. And I mean, it is a disappointment because it's something that you're eligible for. And if you don't get it, then you think about, or at least I think about, what I did to not do it and what I did wrong and how I'm not as decent as a person as other people. And it's just-- I mean, it's a letdown, but it's not everything. And that's what a lot of people lose grip of. That's what I always lose grip of, is that it's not everything, as much as it means. But it means a lot.
我没期待，但我真的、真的想要当队长。我的意思是，这是一种失望，因为这是你有资格去争取的东西。如果你没得到，你就会去想——或者至少我会去想——我做错了什么，或者我哪里不如别人好。这让人很失落，但并不是全部。这是很多人容易失去平衡的一点。这也是我总失去平衡的一点，它并非全部，尽管它意味着很多。但它确实意味着很多。
[CROWD CHANTING AND CHEERING]
[人群呼喊和欢呼]
Over the next two days, it's basically what you'd expect an all-camp competition would be like. The younger girls and older girls split off. They do track and field events, swimming and boating events, scavenger hunts, and an all-camp songfest. Both teams seem pretty evenly matched, and for the most part, the girls win and lose with grace. Most of the girls I talk with all say Color Days is their favorite part of camp. They like the cheering. They like the games. They like feeling a part of a team.
在接下来的两天里，这就是你所期望的全营比赛的样子。低龄和高龄女孩分开。她们参加田径比赛、游泳和划船比赛、寻宝游戏和全营歌会。两支队伍实力相当，大多数情况下，女孩们输赢都表现得优雅。我聊过的多数女孩都说色彩日是她们最喜欢的夏令营部分。她们喜欢加油，喜欢游戏。她们喜欢成为团队一部分的感觉。
[CROWD CHANTING AND CHEERING]
[人群呼喊和欢呼]
But one night, after an intense capture the flag game, where Blue team pulls it off by one point, one of the White team girls doesn't take the loss too well.
但在一个晚上，在一场激烈的夺旗游戏后，蓝队以一分之差获胜，一个白队女孩没太能接受这次失败。
White team, can I talk to you for a second? You guys, the Blue team is playing very dirty, and none of us should play like that at all. They knew I was already over, and yet they still felt that they needed to trip me.
白队，我能跟你们说句话吗？你们这些家伙，蓝队打得太卑鄙了，我们谁都不该那样打。她们明明知道我已经在那边了，还是要把我绊倒。
But just don't complain about it. We're just going to kill them tonight.
但别抱怨了。我们今晚一定要干掉她们。
No, I say we get them back right now by screaming so loud that they will have to plug their ears because that is how upset I am right now.
不，我说我们现在就报复回来，大声尖叫，让她们必须捂住耳朵，因为我现在就是这么生气。
The climax of Color Days is on the last night of camp, the obstacle course relay, where every member of each team takes part. Usually, whoever wins the relay wins the Color Days. The Blue team gathers at their meeting spot on the go-kart track to organize all of the team members for the race. Certain things are clear. Alissa Strom does the longest run. Carly Siegel always does the math problem. Rebecca Stern rules the pie eating contest. But there are some open spots, which require careful consideration.
色彩日的高潮在夏令营的最后一晚，障碍接力赛，每个队员都要参加。通常情况下，谁赢了接力赛谁就赢了色彩日。蓝队在卡丁车赛道的集合点集合，组织所有队员参赛。有些事已经很明确了。艾丽莎·斯特罗姆跑最长的距离。卡莉·西格尔总是做数学题。丽贝卡·斯特恩统治吃派比赛。但还有一些空缺，需要谨慎考虑。
OK. First person--
好了。第一个人——
Shh, you guys. Quiet, OK?
嘘，你们这些家伙。安静，好吗？
This is really important, you guys.
这真的很重要，你们这些家伙。
Really important.
非常重要。
First person is at the flagpole, and they have to eat one peanut butter and jelly sandwich as fast as they can and sing [INAUDIBLE] so fast.
第一个人在旗杆处，她们必须以最快的速度吃完一个花生酱果酱三明治，然后唱（听不清）唱得飞快。
You guys, you are up against Lexie Gore. She is the fastest eater I've ever seen. Yeah. She can shove it in her mouth it's crazy. And so you have to be really, really--
你们要对阵的是莱克西·戈尔。她是我见过吃得最快的人。是的。她能把它塞进嘴里，真是疯狂。所以你们必须非常、非常——
Who's got a big mouth who can eat really fast?
谁嘴大，吃得特别快？
I can eat really fast.
我能吃得特别快。
Jamie?
杰米？
Jamie, you want to try that? Can you eat really fast?
杰米，你想试试吗？你能吃得特别快吗？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[杂乱的声音]
You can sing while you have food in your mouth. You can be like-- [MIMICS TALKING WITH A FULL MOUTH]
你嘴里有食物时也能唱歌。你可以像——（模仿嘴里塞满食物说话的样子）
Jamie, don't eat at dinner.
杰米，晚餐别吃东西。
But it's pizza night. Yeah.
但今晚是披萨之夜。是的。
Doesn't matter.
没关系。
You guys. You guys.
你们这些家伙。你们这些家伙。
After dinner, the captains and the two peanut butter and jelly sandwich eaters gather at the flagpole to begin the race that will last over an hour.
晚饭后，队长和两名花生酱果酱三明治选手在旗杆处集合，开始一场将持续一个多小时的比赛。
On your mark, get set, go.
各就各位，预备，跑。
Come on, Lexie. You got it. You got it.
加油，莱克西。你能行。你能行。
Come on, Jamie.
加油，杰米。
[CHEERING AND CLAPPING]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Go Jamie.
杰米加油。
[CHEERING AND CLAPPING]
[欢呼和鼓掌]
Jamie, amazing. Absolutely amazing. Do you have any idea how much it takes to keep up with Lexie?
杰米，太神奇了。绝对神奇。你知道跟上莱克西需要付出多少努力吗？
The relay race goes all over camp. One camper has to wait for the runner with the baton, then jump in the shower, wash her hair, get out, and passes the baton to the next runner, who goes to the waterfront, where a little girl will do 25 jumping jacks with a life jacket on, who then passes the baton to another girl, who goes all the way back to the other side of camp to a cabin, where a camper unmakes and makes a bed. All along the way, the girls are yelling for their teams, jumping up and down, and trying to control their nerves.
接力赛遍布整个营地。一个营员必须等待拿接力棒的选手，然后跳进淋浴间，洗头，出来，把接力棒传给下一个人，那个人去水边，由一个小女孩穿着救生衣做25个开合跳，然后传给另一个女孩，那个人跑回营地的另一边到宿舍，由一个营员拆开并整理床铺。沿途，女孩们为自己的队伍呐喊、上下跳跃，并试图控制紧张的情绪。
Oh, I am so scared right now. I am, like, here, but I'm not. I'm, like, somewhere else. Go Blue.
哦，我现在太害怕了。我就像在这，但我又不在。我就像在别处。蓝队加油。
Yeah.
是啊。
As an outsider watching three days of all of this, I have to say what was shocking was how gung ho everyone was. Camp is this unusually safe bubble where kids can let themselves go, crying and screaming and singing. They all buy into this. None of them stands back. Nobody thinks they're too cool for it. Back at school, the rules are completely different. Everywhere the rules are completely different.
作为一个旁观者，看着这一切持续三天，我不得不说，让我震惊的是大家居然这么卖力。夏令营是一个极其安全的泡沫，孩子们可以在这里彻底释放自己，哭泣、尖叫和唱歌。她们全盘接受。没有人退缩。没有人认为自己太酷而不屑参与。回到学校，规则完全不同。到处规则都完全不同。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Down at the waterfront, the White and Blue teams stand side by side with dueling cheering, waiting for the final leg of the relay race. When the last baton is passed, the two captains from each team have to build a fire under a rope that's suspended between two sticks about 3 feet off the ground. The first team whose rope catches fire and burns all the way through wins the race. Some Bryn Mawr girls have been saving wood for the burn-the-rope since the second day of camp.
在水边，白队和蓝队站在一起，相互加油，等待接力赛的最后一棒。最后一棒传出时，两队的队长必须在悬挂在两根棍子之间、离地面约3英尺的绳子下生火。第一支让绳子起火并彻底烧断的队伍赢得比赛。布林莫尔的一些女孩从夏令营的第二天起就一直在攒木头以备“烧绳子”。
Tonight, the Blue team has about a full two minutes on the Whites as the runner hands off the baton. The Blue team captains, Carley and Dana, drop to their knees and begin with the kindling. They get only one match a minute as they add twigs and sassafras to the fire.
今晚，当选手交接接力棒时，蓝队比白队领先了整整两分钟。蓝队队长卡莉和戴娜跪下，开始添加引火物。她们每分钟只能得到一根火柴，并往火里加树枝和黄樟木。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Soon the White team starts on their fire. The captains' hands are shaking. Both teams are jumping up and down, cheering and hugging. The first pile of sticks to become like a real fire is the White team's, and the moment it catches, tears start streaming down Carley and Dana's cheeks on the Blue team. Both look close to hyperventilating as they lie down on the dirt, their cheeks on the ground, blowing on their fire, crying and frantically moving sticks around. But the White team's fire rises, their rope starts burning, and once it snaps, the race is pretty much over.
很快，白队也开始生火。队长的手在颤抖。两队都在上下跳跃、欢呼和拥抱。第一堆变成真正火堆的是白队，它点燃的那一刻，蓝队的卡莉和戴娜脸颊上开始流下泪水。两人看起来快要过度换气了，她们趴在泥地上，脸颊贴着地面，对着火堆吹气，哭着拼命移动树枝。但白队的火势升高了，她们的绳子开始燃烧，一旦断裂，比赛基本就结束了。
[SCREAMING AND CHEERING]
[尖叫和欢呼]
Girls are jumping up and down, collapsing into each other's arms, sobbing and laughing. The younger girls, it's almost as if their little bodies can't take all this emotion. I watch one girl, about eight years old, who stands off to the side, begins to tremble, and her face gets redder and redder as tears pour down her cheeks. A teammate tries to comfort her. It's OK, she says, we won.
女孩们在上下跳跃，倒在对方怀里，啜泣着、笑着。低龄女孩们，几乎就像她们的小身体无法承受这么多情绪。我看着一个8岁左右的女孩，她站在一边，开始颤抖，泪水倾泻而下，脸变得越来越红。一个队友试图安慰她。她在那说：“没关系，我们赢了。”
It might seem strange, standing in the middle of a hundred crying girls, that most of them will tell you this is the best day of camp. But it's the best day of camp precisely because it's a hundred girls all crying together. If the point of camp is to feel this camaraderie, to feel like you belong to something, that feeling is at its most concentrated during Color Days. This is also the last day of camp.
站在上百个哭泣的女孩中间，这可能看起来很奇怪，但她们多数人会告诉你这是夏令营最美好的一天。但这正是夏令营最美好的一天，因为这是一百个女孩在一起哭泣。如果夏令营的目的是为了感受这种情谊，感受归属感，那种感觉在色彩日达到最浓郁。这也是夏令营的最后一天。
It's strange. It's this whole thing, there's so many things to deal with. And then it's just all jumbled in at once, and it's confusing and-- I don't know.
很奇怪。这是一个整体，有太多事情要处理。然后一切都混杂在一起，令人困惑，而且——我不知道。
I talk to Jamie Stream and Lexie Cowurtz. Jamie's been here for seven years and can't come back as a camper again. Lexie starts high school this year, and for her, this isn't just the last day of camp, her last day living in this safe little bubble. In a way, it's her last day of childhood.
我和杰米·斯特里姆、莱克西·考沃茨聊了聊。杰米在这里待了七年，以后不能再以营员身份回来了。莱克西今年开始上高中，对她来说，这不仅是夏令营的最后一天，是她住在这个安全小泡沫里的最后一天。在某种程度上，这是她童年的最后一天。
One camp summer has never meant so much to me now that we're getting older. And I'm so frightened of going into high school that I don't want to leave here anyway, but I'm so secure here. It's such a haven for me that I can't imagine going home.
我们长大了，暑期夏令营对我意义重大。我很害怕升入高中，不管怎样我不想离开这，但我在这里很有安全感。这对我来说是一个避风港，我无法想象回家。
Also, I think it's hard, maybe not for you, but for me, since this is my last year, these are my last, like, three days of ever being a camper. And it's so weird. It's like, this is my last Tuesday at camp. This is my last dinner with my cabin. This is my last time ever being in a cabin with my friends. And that's what's so weird about it because you're just thinking about the last this, last that.
另外，我想这很艰难，也许对你来说不是，但对我来说，因为这是最后一年，这是我作为营员最后的日子了。这太奇怪了。就像，“这是我在夏令营的最后一个周二。这是我和宿舍的最后晚餐。这是我和朋友们住在一起的最后时光。”这就是它的怪异之处，因为你满脑子都是“最后一个这个、最后一个那个”。
I'm kind of scared to go home, in a way, because my friends at home are so different from my friends here, and it's going to be scary.
从某种程度上讲，我很害怕回家，因为家里朋友和这里的朋友太不同了，这会很可怕。
They're so dull. I don't mean that as in like-- I mean, I love my friends to death. But when you think of the things that we go through here, we're not really living at home. We go to school, and we go out. And It's not their fault, but the environment is so different that it's dull living at home.
她们太乏味了。我不是那个意思——我是说，我爱死我的朋友们了。但当你想到我们在这里经历的事情时，我们回到家并不算是在真正活着。我们上学，我们出门。这不是她们的错，但环境太不同了，呆在家里很乏味。
I'm perfectly content here just sitting here getting mail. I don't really care as long as I just-- it's so strange. And I'm going to miss walking-- I was just talking to Lauren [INAUDIBLE] about this. I'm going to miss walking down the path. I'm going to miss the doors slamming. I'm going to miss the overflowing bathrooms. It's unreal that we have to leave.
我在这里就很满足，只是坐在这里收信。我真的不在乎，只要我——这太奇怪了。我会想念这里的路——我刚和劳伦（听不清）聊过这个。我会想念走在小径上。我会想念摔门的声音。我会想念溢出来的浴室。我们要离开这里太不真实了。
The stupid little things is what you really miss.
你真正想念的是那些愚蠢的小细节。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Toff, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Markie Rocklin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Harmonica music throughout our hour today by Howard Levy.
好了，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。资深编辑保罗·托夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、马基·罗克林，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。今天的口琴音乐全程由霍华德·利维提供。
Thanks to the staff and campers of Lake on the Woods and Greenwood camps in Michigan. Our program today was recorded there in the summer of 1998. Thanks to historian Philip Deloria, whose book Playing Indian details the history of fake Native American culture in American summer camps.
感谢密歇根州“森林湖”和“格林伍德”夏令营的员工和营员。我们今天的节目是在1998年夏天录制的。感谢历史学家菲利普·德洛里亚，他的书《扮演印第安人》详细记录了美国夏令营中伪美洲原住民文化的历史。
Special shout-out today to Emily Bernstein, whose stories about summer camp a few years ago in The New York Times were an inspiration as we put together today's program.
今天特别向艾米莉·伯恩斯坦致敬，几年前她在《纽约时报》上关于暑期夏令营的报道，是我们筹备今天节目的灵感来源。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can get our free weekly podcast or listen to any of our old shows online for absolutely free. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who calls our contributor Adam Davidson at least once a day to demand--
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以获取我们免费的每周播客或免费在线收听我们任何旧节目。《这就是美国生活》由公共广播国际频道发行。我们的主管托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责节目的管理监督，他每天至少给我们的撰稿人亚当·戴维森打一次电话要求——
It's very funny the way you do this make out thing. Show me do it.
你玩这种亲热游戏的方式很有趣。表演给我看。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
It's very funny, that's all. It's not for anything, but just the funny.
很有趣，就是这样。没别的，就是好玩。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际频道。